we're looking at today and this is very
much the second half of the lesson that
we did on Tuesday we did a lot in that
it was a double to remember actually
just before we get to this what did we
cover on Tuesday like I'm sort of
spoiling some of it but see what you can
recall for me very good so we didn't it
we actually had a look at a table this
one right you remember this we
introduced this guy right and we talked
about the fact that the derivative tells
you it describes the behavior the graph
when you know it's going up going down
it's not going anywhere
okay and we introduced this technical
language right now from here you
remember was a double right the second
thing we only touched on it briefly was
we then discussed and this is why I'm
bringing you back to this sheet here we
then discussed in more detail that
particular part in that table which is
stationary it turns out that's a
particular interest to us when you know
something is for example you know
looking like these two parabola shapes
here right it turns out that finding the
place where that happens is often really
important it's like well I want to know
when it's the highest or when it's the
lowest and that can be for practical
purposes very important to us okay so
what we're gonna do is we're going to
come back to this idea and go through in
some more detail so we're continuing
what we had a look at from Tuesday now I
promised and you can see because most of
the sheet is blank to be honest at the
moment I promised we were going to fill
this in a little more so I want us to do
that right now for starters when we have
a look at the center circle the
stationary points right there's
something that we know about the
derivative that tells us a stationary
point exists can anyone tell me what is
that characteristic we're searching for
it equals zero fantastic so I'd love you
to write down whoopsie-daisy I'd love
you to write down just like above there
is fine the thing that qualifies you the
thing that tells you or stationary point
exists is that you find you solve for
when the derivative is equal to zero now
once you've done that right if you
haven't think back to the lesson on
Tuesday we then wanted to say not just
like hey find me some stationary points
there were two questions that we would
generally ask you we would say where are
they and then those are second
does anyone remember what the second
question was and I introduced some
technical language for exactly very good
tell me what kind of a stationary point
is it and so we just drew these earlier
but what I'd like you to do in here is
that let's label this a little bit
further these two kinds of stationary
points here the one at the top you can
see the stationary points right at the
bottom there so we call this guy a
minimum so I'll come to the language in
a little more detail in a second
this guy at the top is a minimum turning
point because it's at them the lowest
part the minimum right and by contrast
you've got this guy down the bottom this
is a maximum turning point right now in
terms of the language right maximum or
minimum that's singular if you hear
someone say Maxima that's the plural
right it's like ah a graph may have and
this sounds weird right a graph may have
several Maxima now that sounds strange
because the whole idea of a maximum is
it's the highest point there's nothing
higher than that but I'm you don't have
to draw this unless you want to can you
imagine a graph like this okay right now
what you got here
this very very Wiggly graph I don't know
what that might be like a 4x to the 11
or something like that okay you can
clearly see there's a bunch of different
stationery points that could each be
called
the maximum in in their little area does
that make sense okay yeah I don't know
but I can find out for you if you like I
can tell you right now in fact how many
stationery points do you count I've
already put in four those are the maxima
and then there's one two three so there
are seven stationery points so what that
indicates to you is most likely the
derivative to find those seven
stationery points will probably be
something like X to the power of seven
if the derivative is something like X to
the power of seven with some other stuff
what is the actual function like the
theory integrase probably something to
be eight right so anyway as to what
particular things of the eight I'll work
that out later
but my point is let me just go back my
point is each of those could be called a
maximum but they just maximum sort of
relative to the nearby air
so in fact we call them each relative
Maxima we're actually going to delve
into this in a lot more detail later on
which is why I'm making this as a side
point but just because Sarang asked
about maxima which is the Perl minima
which is also a plural maximum and
minimum a singular okay so we have these
two kinds of our stationary points here
which are also turning points as you can
see on the right-hand side okay but we
also noticed that that isn't always what
you get you don't always see in that
table of values right you don't always
see a change from negative gradient to
positive gradient or the other way
around right if you do see that change
in the sign of the derivative that's
what tells you there's a turning point
it's like oh look my um my derivative
used to be positive and now it's
negative that tells me positive then
negative that's a maximum isn't it right
or by contrast it was negative then it
became positive that would mean it's a
minimum right it's not always the case
that that change in sign occurs right
for example it could be positive then
it's stationary and then it's positive
again right so that's not a turning
point as you can see over here on the
left hand side that's this other kind of
stationary point we're interested in so
now I'm going to tell you what these are
called weird-sounding name these are
called horizontal firstly because just
like every other stationary point the
tangent there would be a horizontal line
they called horizontal points of
inflection
that's a weird crazy word the whole idea
here is almost like if you can imagine
taking a ruler and flexing and bending
it right this is kind of that bending
point if you like it as it were sort of
bending is sort of a nice little synonym
for you and in fact point of inflection
is the name of this left hand circle
that we haven't really talked about very
much so these are all whoopsie-daisy
points of inflection and I will just
make a minor point here that where
they're inflection sometimes get spelled
differently sometimes you will see it
spell with
and a CT ir n both of them as far as I
can tell are just different spellings
for the same word okay but you'll see
both of them they mean the same thing